my name's Kate Jones biggest fear of the
day is hitting the wall it's happened to
me once before I've really keen to
understand how to prevent that so one of
the ways to avoid hitting the wall
actually is to make sure you consume
carbohydrate doing the risk to start
early a lot of our life's a mistake that
athletes often make if they consume
carbohydrate but they leave it too late
so really you need to start fueling
right from the very first mile actually
fuel every 20 minutes
hit your carbohydrate targets and
hopefully you won't hit the wall my
biggest worry for marathon day is
getting to the last part of the race and
how my body will react to that you never
really know how your body is going to
feel towards the end of a race each race
can be different any day can be
different the best thing you can do is
prepare and eat very well drink well and
literally go out there and give it your
all so my biggest worry for mouth and
day is getting injured and not finishing
the race running out of steam and
especially failing so the best way to
make sure that you finish the race is to
make sure you start the race in the most
suitable way to finish it which is what
you do in the 24 to 48 hours before the
risk what you do a breakfast and last
but not least is what you do during the
race itself and as we all know
carbohydrate is the most common
denominator across all three of those
time skills so really adhere to best
practice nutrition and trust me you will
finish through it
if you're worried about picking up an
injury or marathon day one of the best
things you can do is really focus on
your technique one of the best ways to
do this is to try and think about your
cadence the how many times your foot
touches the floor per minute probably
the best thing to do is look to increase
your cadence that perhaps shorten your
stride length this way you're going to
put a lot less pressure through your
joints it's going to lighten the load
it's going to make things more simple
less impact and less force and that way
you're going to really reduce your
chance
picking up an injury my name is Emma and
I'm my biggest worry from a Sunday is
I'm probably joint and muscle pain and
just making it three hours in or so and
not quite being able to finish so I'm
here to learn about which gels and
supplements I can take to get me through
the race and to help me recover after
that when it comes to muscle pain during
madison's it's simply unavoidable so I
think the best thing you can do
be mentally prepared for it you're going
to be running from anything from three
to four and a half five hours best thing
you can do is just remember that it is
going to hurt it's going to be painful
but if you want to just put the miles in
during the training trust your training
and that's going to put you in the best
place to handle it when you get into the
later stage of the race